welcome to new video
let's get going it's a five minute game
first one for a while um
i went for d4 um the opponent is called
proust from turkey
okay most likely we get in him zone
okay he opts for the queen's gambit
instead
so play the exchange variation
which
usually is quite comfortable for white
okay place a quick knight f8
it's an old idea to get in g6 and knight
e6 to g7
yeah i've forgotten mostly how this is
played okay let's just develop
okay i don't want to take just yet on f6
let him play g6 and those moves first
okay interesting now
yeah let's let's keep it simple i don't
know the
exact moves here
castles first okay let's
go for the classic minority
attack with before
okay
can i play b5 now immediately
yeah i guess i go for this
okay of course he
could exchange the light squared bishop
which is a
success um for black
because this bishop is usually
quite a bad piece
but still i should have ideas on c6
okay queen a6 now maybe then maybe it's
got c5
i think this one makes sense also to
cover c3
he might go for knight d64 now okay
doesn't do this
maybe just knight a4 to really pluck
this yeah
a5 is just an idea here
didn't play that play it
okay okay let's just take this
outpost on knight c4 i can just play
knight d2
i think to to exchange this
okay i've spent lots of time
going about some details in the opening
okay
okay it's not really a threat
that he might capture there but still i
don't want to exchange too many pieces
i want to try a pile up on on the c pawn
okay
not sure of rook c2 was also possible of
course
this pin is a bit inconvenient here
well the good news is that i managed to
trade off
quite a lot of pieces so it's very
unlikely that you'll get some some
kind of attack going
okay let's
provide some air for the king
this might make sense different
scenarios
so i would like to really take the
queens off if possible
if he lets me he does
okay
yeah of course this is just a
very slight advantage
it's hard to improve the position here
he's only got one weakness and this is
nicely covered also with some activity
okay i'll exchange this now but it will
be very difficult to make any progress
here
it's been rather quick with the king
also
to cover cover this year oh i didn't
look at rook a1
but i get ready for this move
yeah this is just nothing morning i'm
only
down on time
not much hope to get something out of
this
except maybe a draw but this will be
not so simple and because of the time
okay i've got one pair of rooks off
this might increase chances to make at
least a bit of progress
but that still of course a completely
equal position
yeah it simply i cannot do much here
maybe try to make a little bit of
progress on the king side
he's also limited to just sitting and
waiting
basically
maybe f3 g4 let's try this
i could play g5 now maybe okay i try to
to get something going here
h5 might be uh okay
check okay if i capture on g5 you take
e3 and then
my pawn position would fall fall apart
defaults are weak
so i cannot do this
check
check
ah what i did was really risky just see
it
now bbc's gets he's getting the a pawn
check
check
yeah this is lost i think
check
check spend too much time there
check
check
check
okay
grah offered
check
game yeah okay this was the most logical
finish
but i was lucky to to get the draw of
course in the end
because of the time and position yeah
this was just nothing
and maybe i should have also done
nothing
yeah this is a bit problematic here
maybe this would have been okay with
some preparation
check check how well this should be
should be a simple draw but
going for for this here it was
was very risky maybe just king d3 and
stay put and it's just a draw
and
this was getting getting a bit risky of
course
because this is bad of course just just
rookie five here
but i didn't have didn't have much time
okay
let's go to the next game